le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
à la réunion on dénombre plus de 40000
aidants familiaux
peu reconnu ces personnes s'occupent
avec dévouement de proches âgées malades
ou handicapées
un quotidien parfois lourd qui les isole
de la société pour soutenir les aidants
familiaux
le département a mis en place plusieurs
dispositifs comme le café des aidants ou
leur et piropo pour mieux comprendre
l'importance de ces actions nous partons
à la rencontre de mariam et de son
aidantes marie thérèse
on va ramasser une boîte ou réajuster un
coussin c'est le quotidien de marie
thérèse voilà 50 ans qu'à l'été dante
familiale mariam est atteinte de
myopathie depuis l'enfance elle a 5 ans
lorsque marie thérèse âgé de 17 ans
vient s'installer dans leur maison
familiale à saint denis
elle est venue ici hand en 67
parce que j'avais deux ce qui était nous
partons moi donc il fallait faire des
soins et mes parents si kaka pour
l'aider et de mama mois à saint denis
mais tous sont mal de santé du sein ne
pas revenir sur saint denis et donc
savourer un trajet à l'époque
et donc après maladie bon bain igad à 10
que des d'accord j'ai dit oui et puis
ben voilà jusqu'à maintenant on a fait
comme si durs et c'était une famille
depuis les deux femmes ne se quittent
plus celle que mariam appelle désormais
maman veille sur sa fille adoptive jour
et nuit à la normale sont
médicalisé et moi je dors à côté d'elle
comme ça quand elle m'appelle je suis la
presse pas besoin de sortir très loin
pour venir l'aider
une vie rythmée par les contraintes de
la maladie la myopathie attaque les
muscles et paralyse peu à peu mariam
dans ces conditions l'aide est l'amour
de marie thérèse sont indispensables ma
bm quoi il faut faire bien sonnés il
faut donner à manger
elle me prépare parce que je la connais
pas par semaine c'est un travail qu'elle
peut être avec un dîner à la maison mais
parce que skype laisser ça fait llp ça
ça fond de son coeur avait toujours
souriant toujours dit bouée
c'est pas toujours trouvé ça je pense
qualité est là reste au montpied jetons
pied devant et deux mois c'est on dirait
c'est ma passion
parce qu'il pourrait être 365 jours
nuitées jour même qu'on sorte on est
ensemble et donc il faut vraiment une à
la force le courage et la patience des
toits simard son ensemble donc aucun
souci
malgré tout certains jours sont plus
difficiles que d'autres
et lorsque le courage vient à manquer et
donc sommes aidés peuvent compter sur un
petit coup de pouce venu de l'extérieur
depuis plus d'un an le département
organise des rencontres dédiées aux
aidants familiaux
tous les mois marie thérèse seront au
café des aidants
ce dispositif offre un espace de parole
conviviale encadré par un psychologue
pour que chacun puisse partager son
expérience et ses difficultés
ça ne m'a apporté quand même pas mal d
échanges et de sortie ça me permet aussi
d'évaluer un petit peu si je peux
rapporter un petit peu le un petit
message qu'il connaît pas et donc je
j'en parle avec eux parce que si c'est
pas si ces deux nouveaux qui arrivent
jeudi ben il faut pas baisser les bras
même site on a un papa ou un frère ou
n'importe quoi qui a cette maladie a
tellement maintenant la maladière et
s'installe et donc je dis bas et on
prend toujours du bon côté
parler du quotidien mais aussi s'en
éloigner pour quelques jours
le répit repos est un autre dispositif
départemental
objectif offrir aux familles un moment
de détente
chaque année marie thérèse et mariam
attendent avec impatience leur week-end
au village corail à saint-gilles
transport adapté d'un galop aménagé ici
elles peuvent se détendre et profiter
des services capables de puiser ses
pieds sur la table et c'est pour moi est
le week-end et donc je suis vraiment
vraiment content ce week-end paul série
cancun au programme visite du port de
plaisance et de ses environs mère et
fille compte bien profiter de ce moment
de partage au bord de l'eau
le département s'engage pour soutenir
les aidants et leurs familles ces
actions viennent d'être reconnus et
récompensés par l'europe
le conseil départemental est la première
collectivité d'outre-mer à recevoir le
label européen de convivialité et de
solidarité pour sa politique des deux
réunionnais je crois qu'aujourd'hui la
reconnaissance qui nous est donnée à
travers ce prix reconnaît l'action que
nous avons menée sur les aidants
familiaux qui sont un peu des bénévoles
mais les bénévoles professionnels parce
que à force de temps ils ont appris ils
ont compris également comment il fallait
éviter à sacrifie souvent de toute une
vie quand on a une personne porteuse
d'un handicap dans la famille et quand
on est pas un c'est une souffrance et
c'est en même temps une joie il faut
donc donner les moyens pour que le coeur
est confiant et que l'amour continuent à
agrandir en essayant d'aider ces aidants
familiaux
le café des aidants est un espace de
rencontre et les changes pour les
aidants familiaux
il se tient trois fois par mois le
mercredi matin ou jeudi après-midi à la
case grand air à l'antre-2 et le
mercredi après midi à l'espace raid les
deux saint denis le dispositif répit
rupo offre une palette de services qui
vise à soulager le quotidien des
familles et dante
parmi eux l'action grand air permet à
l'aidant et à l'aider de profiter de
deux ou trois jours dans un centre de
loisirs adapté pour profiter de ces
services ou pour plus d'informations
vous pouvez vous adresser à la maison de
l'aide à la personne au 13 rue fénélon à
saint-denis ou appeler le numéro vert 0
800 53 00 02
m